this is a perfect segue now to the
oscarssowhite situation because Fox News
had stacey dash on who's black and she
was saying you sorta to the black
community she was just like get over it
that this is not an important thing so
that we have decided that we will take a
deal and give us a you basically one arm
that's a fair trade
you are basically our number one white
person right now and you're you could
take station she was in one movie I
think in 1995 clueless that's what we're
getting who we want to do that was
trending on tone and black Twitter so
just the power of social media
yes she's entitled to her opinions and I
don't necessarily put Stacy in this
category I don't know her personally but
there are people of every race every
persuasion that have branded themselves
as we started this conversation as
experts they like the attention that
they get from saying outlandish things
they like to be provocative on topics I
don't know if this is her like I don't
know her personally but I do know
because I sit in this chair and I sit on
these shows you know four or five times
a week and some of these folks I know
that they're intentionally trying to be
provocative but she may believe that
african-americans should get over it I
say again to her she's misguided in her
thoughts and her statements and you have
to look at the history none of this
happens in a vacuum and for those folks
who say or what about the n-double-a-cp
Image Awards they're all black and what
about Beatty it's all black
why aren't white actors complaining
about that and I say well just look at
the history right why is there an N
double ACP why are there n double acp
Image Awards right I mean I look I have
no problem with her saying whatever she
if she believes it look even if she's
just saying it to say it cuz she's on
television that's part of the game yeah
that's some other saying and if she
believes it then she believes it I
thought the one part that was a little
odious really was that she said that we
shouldn't have a Black History Month
which every it's part of our culture
everything we should have a black hist
month we should have a Latino history
mud then that's gonna do away with
everything that identifies or celebrates
its culture let's start with Columbus
Day all right so Oscar so here we go so
there is a big brouhaha right now we got
a hashtag on Twitter gone and a lot of
the black community is not happy about
this I should say right up front that
Chris Rock the guy who's gonna host the
thing who said he's still gonna host it
is black the president of the Academy is
black but I think ninety-four percent of
the voters are white I hope I'm getting
it was ninety four percent of the
account of the Academy 77% of them
voters are white male yeah so okay so
there are some numbers now I also saw
some numbers that were that since 2000
that pretty much it's been about that
the black community America is about 10
percent or about 12% and they've gotten
about 10 percent of the nominations so
that since 2000 that it basically works
out so I'm just throwing out some
numbers to start I think that again I
love protests let me just start because
it works yeah so sharable isaacs came
out and said change needs to happen but
it needs to happen faster she was
frustrated she was heartbroken Jada
Pinkett Smith did her facebook video to
her 7 million viewers and we had Spike
Lee make his statement and guess what
happened there was an emergency meeting
on the agenda was this issue of
diversity for the Academy and out of
that emergency meeting came some
commitments that were pretty significant
like we are going to diversify our
membership by 2020 we're gonna add more
women we're going to add more minorities
and we're going to make the issue of
diversity a bigger issue for the Academy
and it makes sense you know I didn't
tell you this I went to Harvard for Law
School but my major in college was
economics so some of this stuff just
boils down to money yeah I think
something you wanted to be an actress
look at the facts here yeah last year
they said the ratings down
sixteen percent and a lot of that was
attributed to last year when there were
no black nominees and that hashtag
trended Oscars so white the Oscars
shurl they had a job to do it's the end
of the day they gotta sell a television
program to a network and the network has
to bring in sponsors and advertisers
they're gonna make a lot of money right
so imagine if that 16 percent grew to 25
percent because high profile
african-americans like Spike Lee and
Will Smith and Marlon Wayans and Jada
Pinkett Smith all said I'm not going to
watch attending and to that point if
there were more black people nominated
it's not like suddenly white people
would be like I'm not watching this no
there were some more black nominees is
ridiculous but do you think there's a
little risk though in that this this is
forgetting the politics side of it we
know there's plenty of politics for
Hollywood but that these are subjective
Awards so it is possible do you think it
is possible I should say that the people
voted and they just happen to the votes
just worked out there's no anything that
that's a possibility
really absolutely not yeah because what
we're hearing is that the membership
they get to watch whatever movies they
choose to watch yeah so if I'm a 78 year
old white guy okay and I got all these
movies to watch what are the chances
that I'm gonna watch straight out of
Compton it's just not likely it and
here's what African Americans want it
and I've heard so that's interesting so
that's not necessary so that's almost
you would say that sort of racist by
omission
that's why diversity matters uh in some
of us as long we don't want affirmative
action for the awards no we don't want
affirmative action we just want the
Academy to reflect the reality of movie
goers so 46% of all tickets sold at the
box office or from minorities so if the
people buying your product by and large
all we're saying is let the Academy
reflect those people and at the end of
the day if an African American or Latino
decides that Straight Outta Compton
isn't a movie that they want to vote for
it to be best picture of the year okay
we don't live with that
we're not asking that it get any special
treatment all we're asking for is
diversity so that at least there
some confidence that the process is fair
even the playing field don't give us any
greater advantage just you know Viola
Davis says it's best the difference
between black women and TV and white
women are the opportunities so we're
really just talking about opportunities
and Spike Lee I think was spot-on saying
this happens way before we get to the
award seasons this is happening in the
sea suites at Studios because when we
look at who can greenlight projects
that's where we've got to start there's
no diversities no Africa I think he told
me that I think he said there's one
African American that has the power to
greenlight a project so it starts with
like a major studio project a major
studio yes obviously not independent
films but it starts with those the
number of and Whoopi Goldberg talked
about this on the view as a director and
an executive producer is that the black
directors and writers and producers they
cannot get their projects through
mainstream studios and when they do
their budgets are smaller and
opportunities for success on those
projects but just again I'm gonna go
back to my economics right so yeah go to
that you have straight out of Compton
making 200 million dollars you have
right along three pushing Star Wars out
of the top slot hmm I think somebody
ought to take note the bean counters the
accountants the money people ought to be
taking note of that and and ought to do
what teenie has done to recognize hey
there's there's some money in these
urban movies and that to me that's the
interesting part because if I know one
thing about now living in LA and being
part of Hollywood or whatever this is is
that this town I think basically is just
run by people want to make money that
that it's a capitalistic town it's not
like that so your argument though would
would prove if you they said all right
guys we're looking at the numbers here
46% of the people that are coming to
movies are minorities then we should be
trying to increase that percentage of
the pie it's not gonna come at the cost
necessarily of your white viewer is that
I think the town would be would go for
that because they they want to make
money but I think that's the fear Dave
you hit on something really important
and we're seeing that in the
presidential election this fear that if
I make way for you african-american
minority somehow that means there's no
way for me right oh your your success
comes at my expense and this is also
what you should have learned I'm sure
you have about this town it's very
relationship driven sure so if you know
if I don't have that relationship with
you I'm not necessarily even going to
get in the room to have the meeting and
again to Spike Lee's point if we don't
have more diversity in the top jobs in
upper level management in the
decision-making positions then maybe I'm
never even in the conversation yeah you
know it's funny I saw our friend Larry
elder who we've now mentioned a few
times here I saw he was tweeting at
Spike and basically was saying come on
Spike you've made you know hundreds of
millions of dollars you're selling your
mansion in New York for thirty five
million bucks it's a little disingenuous
for you now I think I know what you're
gonna say to this but I think it's
interesting that it's good at least that
any community is having those internal
fight yeah but again look how ridiculous
that argument you can sit here and say
oh come on
your son has autism so when you're
standing up fighting for more autistics
or services for people with autism
that's just about enriching your own
son's life oftentimes it's people's own
personal experiences that causes them to
become advocates or activists and it is
because of Spike Lee's position inside
the movie industry that he has the voice
and the credibility to speak to it I
surely don't have any credible voice
about making a movie I've never made a
damn movie so who wants to hear from me
about that you want to make a movie no I
don't want to talk about the folks that
make I think his argument is
disingenuous and I think Spike Lee is in
the best position and he's been on this
point he's not new to this party if you
look at the history of Spike Lee in
Spike Lee will tell you lots of projects
he didn't get because he's always been
outspoken about this issue of race and
diversity and inclusion and yes he's
made a lot of money and make more of it
right I'm very uh nyah-nyah in the same
fight in reality that a lot of his
movies were about fired and so
made his move it's not like he's coming
out of nowhere with it and he's hired
yeah and this is a statistic I didn't
even know until he got this honorary
Oscar himself he's hired more
african-american actors than any studio
bar none so here's one guy who has not
had you know a slew of blockbuster
movies but yet he has made it a point to
hire more african-american actors and he
took accepted that award with Sam
Jackson and Denzel washing out a KERS
black white green no matter what you
know and they were there because they've
been in so many of his movies you know
it just hit me as we're talking about
this that it's so sad that so much has
to be you know framed within within the
racial lens because we haven't gotten it
there yet because I've had jackée Harry
on my field who was the first black
woman to ever win an Emmy and I remember
watching to to say that when I was like
I was probably 10 or 12 and I remember
thinking this woman is absolutely
hysterical yes I didn't look at her and
think oh there's a black woman making me
laugh I just look this woman is
hysterical and I guess you know talent
ultimately is what has to reach the top
but that doesn't mean that some of these
systemic things can't be and that's
again that's for people we're not
talking per se about affirmative action
but people I think get that wrong we're
not asking that you lower the standards
we're asking that you even the playing
field and that's a very big difference
what would you say to the people I've
seen this bubble up a little bit lately
that people are saying well if you look
at the Latino community they're their
numbers in America versus their
nominations or the Asian community
really that they they never get
nominated basically so I see a lot of
people saying well the black community
is fighting the wrong fight here they're
fighting something that makes everyone
else go how you're fighting about Oscars
nobody cares about Oscars while the
Latino community is way less represented
and you know that is a fantastic
question and right look at the history
what do black people do we break the
damn doors down so everybody else the
gays the Latinos the Asians women can
walk through the door so watch what
happens when diversity happens I gonna
just be about black actors it's gonna be
about diverse actors it's gonna be
Latinos Asians people with disabilities
they will all benefit somebody has to
lead on this and if you look
historically it's been african-americans
who've been willing even though you're
right disproportionately our numbers are
much smaller than Latinos yeah but we
have a much more organized and developed
system of protesting and raising issues
of racial inequality in this country
then Latinos and Asians and trust me
when we break the doors down nobody else
is saying oh my god they broke that damn
door down watch that door is too broken
yeah watch everybody run through that
door so I would say to Latinos Asians
stand up with us we all benefit from
this we're not saying that it's all
black actors I want us I'm a woman I
want to see more females I want to see
I'm a disability rights advocate I'm
gonna see more individuals with
disabilities portrayed in movies in
television so I think nothing but good
from any marginalized group comes from
the efforts of what we see happening on
this Oscars so white yeah in a way it
shows the strength of the black
community actually because because a lot
of what we care about culturally and the
music we listen to and and all of that
stuff comes from the black community so
it's like in a way the black community
has to lead on this for the other
minority so it does kind of make sense
and for those folks to say oh my god you
know this is a bunch of millionaires
fighting about a cold statue who cares
the Oscars are a very important
institution and the entertainment
industry particularly in a state like
California is huge and again if we're
buying 46 percent of the tickets at the
box office this is an issue that we need
to be aware of does it mean that we
don't care about hunger does it mean
that we don't care about poverty and the
poverty and the fact that you know one
out of three black kids live in poverty
no and we our capacity is large enough
that we can fight the fight on poverty
as well as address issues at the Oscars
I don't see them as mutually exclusive
at all